I have never seen a film that looks like
Dick Tracy and I know a lot of people
say that all this imagery isn't like
anything you've ever seen in blah blah
blah but it's really true I can't think
of any other movie that looks like this
this might be the most ambitious Lee
visual spectacle I've seen in years
it's crazy the colors the designs the
costumes the makeup it's totally insane
which is why it really sucks that I
can't remember a single friggin thing
about it is it that the visuals were so
good it distracted from the rest of the
story or is it that the story wasn't
really that hot to begin with Dick Tracy
based on the famous newspaper comic
strip is the yellow trench coat wearing
cop played by Warren Beatty who's trying
to take down the massive crime in his
fair city his arch nemesis Big Boy
played by Al Pacino is the yelling and
screaming mob gangster who constantly
wants to put him out of his way he comes
across a kid simply named kid a singer
named breathless Mahoney played by
Madonna and all sorts of weird and
literally colorful characters that
constantly want to kill it there's
flat-top babyface the blank they only
get crazier and crazier okay so the
basic story is good guys versus bad guy
has cute kid sidekick has a femme fatale
all the classic stuff you usually see in
a lot of film noir is and so on that
part is easy to follow what's not easy
to follow it's the steps they're taking
to create this formula there's a lot of
talk of business a lot of talk of fraud
a lot of talk a strategy a lot of talk
of planning a lot of talk of breaking in
busting a person and yeah we see it
happen but what do we really know about
these people
aside from Al Pacino who's really
yucking it up as the bad guy there's
nothing memorable about these characters
Warren Beatty is a tough cop and that's
about it
Madonna is the hot singer and that's
about it the wisecracking kids a
wisecracking kid and that's about it you
get where I'm going with this
hearing them talk is not very riveting
and it's constantly being distracted by
how incredible the backgrounds
when the action finally does start it
looks pretty cool but what do I care if
a these people get axed off a part of me
kind of respects that they're trying to
take such a cartoon Elise illy looking
film so seriously but on the other hand
I just wish it could have been more
interesting I remember on the credit
that said that Dick Van Dyke was in this
movie Dick Van Dyke where the hell was
he
oh there he is god I didn't even notice
him he's in and out of the film so fast
that he's barely even worth the credit
if Dick Van Dyke dick Van freaked and I
can't leave an impact on you in a movie
you know there's got to be something
wrong with it on top of that there's a
lot of scenes in the movie they're just
downright gruesome especially for a
Disney film bruit on they take this one
gangster down by tying him up playing
him in a box covering him and when
cement and then throwing him in the
river all while he's crying and sobbing
the whole time that's pretty fucking
intense don't get me wrong I like a
little dark and gritty in Disney films
but it's like something right out of a
nightmare I guess to the film's credit
it's not that it's really bad or
annoying it's just kind of dull like I
said I can barely remember what actually
happened in this movie I just remember
it looked beautiful while it was
happening with that said yeah it is
friggin unbelievable to look at I mean
who would dressed this way who would
design their buildings this way who
would choose these colors who would have
faces this bizarrely weird nobody would
its obviously taking the idea of
adapting the comic strip which was very
bright colorful and over-the-top to a
whole new level it's definitely in its
own unique world one where the
backgrounds don't even have to look that
convincing I mean look at this this is
so obviously a matte painting they're
not even trying to hide the brushstrokes
but that's just part of the style
it all looks phony but in the same way
that a puppeteer holding a puppet you
know is phony but you don't care it's
just so well done that you enjoy every
second of it so I'm kind of torn on the
movie on the one hand I'm glad I saw it
if for any other reason
just to see it but on the other hand
yeah why couldn't they make the story
more interesting like only flesh out the
characters more why couldn't they be a
lot more fun like I said Pacino is great
but everyone else is just so phoned in
standard just because they look to stink
doesn't mean they act distinct I
remember the makeup in the layout much
more they remember anything else in this
bill that's really a shame if this did
have a memorable story and characters
maybe it could be like one of the great
film noir a film that plays to
incredibly heavy shadows but also
somehow incredibly heavy colors it could
have been sort of this one-of-a-kind
masterpiece but as is is really just a
style over substance movie if you want
to see the style and you just enjoy
watching people and trench coats and
fedora hats punch each other and shoot
then you'll at least be glad that you
saw it but if none of that does it for
you then I'm sad to say this is a very
unfortunate skip